it's quite Sunny isn't it it's amazing
it's amazing uh it's just a privilege to
be in these films that alone to me at
the end of this entire Journey it's like
another level really and um I'm really
excited to see the film I haven't seen
it I mean well I don't know yet because
I haven't seen it but you know all the
spectacle with another Year's Evolution
you know and Pete's the filmmaker he can
tell you what the differences are and
you know what part of the Machinery is
going to bring you an extra added thrill
but I mean honestly to see this and Star
Trek as well yeah IMAX is an
extraordinary experience for films on
this scale it's really the best way to
see them and it's so immersive so all
inclusive you feel you are surrounded by
Middle Earth which is pretty terrifying
it's epic but contains geography isn't
it you know you've got mountain ranges
Lakes classes you know you've got sandy
beaches you've got Cliffs you've got
rugged pastures you've got the whole
kind of Monopoly of stuff that you need
for this fictional landscape and it's
all there it's all New Zealand and that
was one of the big drawers of doing the
job I just wanted to get down there and
have some fun and go walking and you
know get on the river and have some fun
I did I love it I was and I was a
genuine fan of the books my Dad read
them to me when I was young and I was
yeah I was transported but he's an actor
so he knows what he's doing but I
they're incredibly imaginative reached
they're really thick with detail and
they're sort of rivetingly paced and you
know at the center of them you've got
this extraordinary quiet hero this uh
small man small in expectations as well
not just size this Hobbit and it's just
uh it's an amazingly sort of uplifting
sort of
love him I can't believe this is the
last time we're going to see his
performance as well there are so many
lasts tonight it's kind of it's kind of
sound you know I think for people that
have been part of this like Ian has from
the beginning absolutely it will be but
I mean you know it's a celebration
it's a celebration it's a great it's a
great send-off